HéHélène Buzzetti, Michel C. Aur
etet Luc Ferrandez,
bobonsoir à vous trois.
- - Bonsoir!
- - On va commencer par ce plane
M.M. Dubé, ministre de la santé,
ququi est venu expliquer en dirt
enen tout début d'émission. Pett
exextrait de l'esprit de ce pla.
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
etet Services sociaux, Québec
- - C'est fini les rapports.
IlIl faut passer à l'action. Eta
papandémie nous oblige à le fai.
LeLes Québécois méritent mieux.
JeJe pense que si on travaille
totout le monde ensemble, non
seseulement dans les prochains
momois mais dans les prochaines
anannées, on sera capables de
lilivrer la marchandise. Un
enengagement, on aura le courage
dede faire les bonnes actions.
- - Vous avez tous plusieurs
anannées d'expérience derrière
vovous, vous en avez vu passer s
rarapports, des promesses
élélectorales. Hélène, je commee
avavec vous. Qu'est-ce qui nous
gagarantit que c'est la bonne?
- Peut-être le fait que ce n'est
papas spectaculaire comme rappo,
cocomme proposition plutôt. On e
nonous promet pas de grandes
memesures. On arrive plutôt avec
dedes choses très circonscrites.
PePeut-être que ça la solution
jujustement, des changements qui
nene sont pas spectaculaires mas
ququi pourrait amener une
momodification à long terme.
EÉvidemment, ces fameux guichets
ununiques pour pouvoir accéder à
dedes professionnels, c'est une
pepetite révolution qu'on nous
anannonce et qui m'apparaît
inintéressante. Cependant, je vs
unun risque. Si se n'est pas
cocombinée avec un dossier
ininformatisé unique par patien,
onon va se retrouver peut-être
dadans quelques années avec une
gégénération de patients orphels
ouou de patients itinérants qui
vovont avoir comme cela des bous
dede leur dossier médical un peu
papartout, répartis en toutes
sosortes de spécialistes.
CÇa me semble à long terme
rereprésenter un risque s'il n'a
papas cette concentration du
dodossier médical.
- - Donc une mise à jour de la
dodocumentation. C'est de
l'l'organisation dont on parle
icici. Michel, vous en avez vu
papasser plusieurs. Celui-là, e-
cece qu'il vous semble
susuffisamment réaliste pour avr
unune chance?
- - La bonne nouvelle, c'est un
pepeu ce qui Hélène disait auss,
onon n'a pas de refondation. No,
vovoici ce qui s'est dit depuis
plplusieurs années. Ça, c'est ue
bobonne nouvelle. La moins bonn,
d'd'une part il y a ce guichet
ununique, je ne pense pas que ça
bebeaucoup marché dans la fonctn
pupublique ou dans l'appareil
gogouvernemental. Et deuxièmeme,
çaça implique une augmentation e
pepersonnel importante et des
memesures de rétention du
pepersonnel important. Ce qui va
cocoûter très cher. Alors, est-e
ququ'ils sont capables d'avoir s
mimilliers d'infirmières de plu.
EsEst-ce qu'ils sont capables
d'd'avoir des milliers d'adjoin?
OnOn est en situation de pénurie
dede personnel partout. La dureé
dudu travail, on l'a vu, dans ls
hhôpitaux, au cours des derniers
momois, c'est vraiment très dur.
CeCe n'est pas nécessairement ce
ququi va amener les gens dans ce
sesecteur, même si on abolit le
tetemps supplémentaire
obobligatoire.
- - C'est un des grands défis,
cocomme le disait le ministre, e
rerendre ce secteur attrayant.
MaManifestement, il y a une côtà
momonter.
- - Il y a de gros jeux de domis
dadans le plan de Dubé.
SiSi les pièces tombent sur les
auautres, il aura gagné. S'il
totombait ne touche pas les
auautres, il aura perdu.
IlIl compte engager 1000
ininfirmières pour qu'elle puise
reremplacer lorsqu'il y aura des
ababsences. Il y a beaucoup
d'd'absentéisme chez les
ininfirmières. Si on n'en a pour
leles remplacer, il n'y aura pas
dede temps supplémentaire, bing.
OnOn ouvre 2010 sans construire
d'd'autres hôpitaux. Il est préu
dede rencontre de nouveau, mais
leles deux premiers mille lits..
etet ce qu'on fait à ce moment-,
c'c'est qu'on envoie beaucoup de
gegens qui sont dans les urgencs
vevers des étages supérieurs eta
lilibère beaucoup de travail por
leles infirmières aussi. Ce
prpremier jeu de dominos. Le
dedeuxième, c'est que si on file
leles appels, par exemple avec e
sysystème du Bas-Saint-Laurentùu
onon dit par exemple : vous, vos
avavez besoin d'avoir un
pspsychothérapeute, en fonctione
vovotre médication. Il y a donoc
momoins de travail qui arrive ax
mémédecins.
EtEt après cela, on ne la loi 11
ququi dit qu'on va prendre les
papatients orphelins avant de ls
rerenvoyer à...
- - c'est un gros risque, et le
tetemps pour le faire, d'ici la
fifin de la session, d'ici la fn
dede la campagne électorale, c't
asassez court. M. Dubé avait
l'l'ambition que la moitié des
papatients orphelins, ils sont
enenviron... c'est un délai quia
asassez court. Mais il y a aussi
unune sorte de réforme même dans
lala philosophie. Ce qui était
vevendu dans la dernière campage
élélectorale, c'était un médecin
dede famille pour chaque
ququébécois. Ce n'est pas ce qun
fafait en ce moment. Est-ce quea
vava passer auprès de la
popopulation?
- - C'est justement ce que je
didisais tout à l'heure.
JuJustement, on a transformé la
prpromesse en disant au départ n
mémédecin par québécois".
LaLa promesse, elle se
mémétamorphose dans un court las
dede temps. À court terme, c'est
clclairement... Ce sera
prprobablement bienfaiteur, pare
quque les gens qui veulent être
trtraités vont aimer pouvoir alr
vevers le bon spécialiste.
MaMais si on abandonne cette ide
d'd'avoir un médecin de famille
popour chaque québécois, qu'il
sosoit suivi, c'est le cas long
teterme les problèmes vont se
mamanifester, parce que les gens
n'n'auront pas de suivi global.
IlIls vont juste comme cela allt
àà la pièce faire traiter leurs
prproblèmes.
- - Vous êtes d'accord avec cela
LuLuc? Ça représente un défi,
paparce que les gens doivent
emembarquer là-dedans. Quand vos
vovoulez voir un médecin, vous e
vovoulez pas voir un ambulancie.
- - Tout à fait. La médecine
hoholistique ça a fait ses
prpreuves, notamment les policis
lalaissés. Il y a des gens qui t
bebesoin d'avoir un suivi, c'es-
àà-dire qu'elles vont revenir de
fafaçon courante, quotidienne
prpresque parfois, parce qu'ells
onont des douleurs. Le médecin s
a a rencontrés déjà, on sait qun
nene peut pas résoudre ces dolls
. . Il faut encadrer ces persons
dede manière ferme. Les personns
ququi ont des maladies chroniqu,
leles personnes âgées... Mme
BuBuzzetti a parfaitement raiso.
- - Les gens dans la salle, on s
a a entendu applaudir après le
popoint de presse. On était dans
unun hôpital pour le point de
prpresse en question. Il y avait
bebeaucoup de monde qui bien das
lele domaine hospitalier.
L'L'absence de la fixe... elles
sosont indispensables les
ininfirmières et les infirmiers.
MiMichel, là-dessus, on sent que
çaça va être un gros défi.
MoMonsieur Dubé ne veut pas
prprendre les gens de façon
frfrontale, mais on sent que çae
sesera pas facile.
- - Non, pour deux raisons. Pare
ququ'elle est la première lignee
totout le réseau. Deuxièmement,
paparce qu'on ne veut une certae
raradicalisation de la direction
dede la figue depuis quelques
momois. C'est bien compréhensib,
paparce qu'ils ont fait faire ds
prpromesses souvent les
ininfirmières, elles n'ont pas é
tetenues souvent. Alors je
n'n'accorderai pas beaucoup
d'd'importance sur le fait qu'ee
n'n'était pas là aujourd'hui, ms
ilil va falloir que le
gogouvernement reconnaisse la
didifficulté de ce travail,
ququ'elle soit mieux compensée.a
prpremière chose à faire, c'este
tetemps supplémentaire
obobligatoire. C'est cela qui et
unun peueu le début de toutes ls
didifficultés.
- - Ça a l'air d'être un défi
ininsurmontable arrêter le temps
susupplémentaire obligatoire. On
esest toujours sous l'impression
ququ'on est devant le fait la
popoule.
J'J'ai toujours du mal de voir
paparce qu'elle porte de sortien
prprend cela.
- - Ça sera pas miraculeux, ça
c'c'est certain.
- - Le temps supplémentaire
obobligatoire a été réduit jusqà
momoins de 1 % dans certains
prprojets pilote, d'abord dans s
prprojets où on travaille avec
l'l'horaire 12-12-12. Encore une
fofois, ça ne règle pas le
prproblème.
- - Et ce n'est pas tout le mone
ququi veut des horaires comme ç.
- - Non, ce n'est pas tout le
momonde. Mais si on fait de
l'l'autogestion avec l'horaire -
1212-12, ça semble donner des bs
rérésultats. Ça se fait, ça
exexiste.
- - On va écouter les réactions
dedes partis de l'opposition.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Aujourd'hui, si vous n'avez
papas de médecin de famille
chchez vous, on vous dit que vos
n'n'en aurez pas plus avec la C.
VIVINCENT MARISSAL, porte-parole
dede QS en matière de santé
- - ça, pour moi, c'est la preue
quque c'est un programme électol
ququ'ils sont en train de tester
àà quelques mois des élections.
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chchef, Parti québécois
- - Le constat, c'est que ce n't
papas un plan gouvernemental,
c'c'est un programme électoral.
- - Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un pu
dede vrai là-dedans? Est-ce que
totout cela ne va pas se
trtransformer en promesses
élélectorales?
- - Oui, peut-être. En même tem,
cocomme je vous le disais, il ny
a a pas de grands feux d'artifi.
OnOn verra cet automne si pour
acaccompagner cette vision qu'on
nonous a présenté aujourd'hui iy
auaura des annonces de
fifinancements qui deviendront s
prpromesses électorales. Mais il
fafaut quand même remarquer qu'l
y y a un fossé aujourd'hui entre
leles critiques, et d'autre par,
cocomme le mentionnait Michel, e
fafait que la plupart des corpse
mémétiers dans le milieu médical
onont bien accueilli la réforme
auaujourd'hui. C'est ce qui m'a
bebeaucoup frappé. Il y avait ue
ququasi-unanimité positive enves
cece qu'annonçait le gouverneme.
C'C'est ce qui m'amène à prendre
avavec un plus gros grain de sel
quque d'habitude les critiques e
l'l'opposition.
- - Michel, on se rappelle les
prpromesses de la dernière
cacampagne électorale. Mais ente
leles deux, il y a eu ce qu'on
apappelle une pandémie. Alors
nénécessairement, comment dire,l
y y a quand même des raisons por
lelesquelles les choses auraient
ddû être faites et qui n'ont pas
étété fait jusqu'à maintenant. t
onon est devenu très critique
enenvers le système de santé.
RaRappelons-nous quand nous
exexpliquait parfois déconfinemt
paparce qu'il fallait protéger
jujustement le système de santé.
- - Cela dit, je pense que la
réréaction positive des gens das
lala salle, je pense qu'il y a
dadans le réseau de la santé en
gégénéral, et même chez les
ininfirmières, même si la
didirection syndicale n'est peu-
êêtre pas de ce côté encore, ily
a a une espèce de volonté que ça
mamarche. Et M. Dubé, même par a
pepersonnalité, et quelqu'un qui
n'n'est pas croissant, qui essae
d'd'adoucir les angles. Cette ie
dede dire : je ne ferai pas la
neneuvième réforme Dubé pour tot
chchanger dans le système, on va
prprendre des choses qui sont dà
llà, qu'on a déjà vu, et qui sot
dadans d'autres rapports, et ona
esessayer de les appliquer. Je
pepense que les gens n'étaient s
prprêts à une grande réforme à a
babarrette.
- - Et c'est pourquoi il enlevat
lele mot "réformation".
- - Exactement.
- - Bon, voilà. Fin du sujet. On
vava passer à notre sujet, parce
ququ'il y avait deux autres
anannonces.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU, premier minise
dudu Canada
- - C'est un plan ambitieux et
reresponsable. Ce plan historiqe
vava nous permettre de réduire s
émémissions de 40 % d'ici 2030 r
rarapport au niveau de 2005 et e
réréaliser nos objectifs de
neneutralité carbone d'ici 2050.
- - Là-dessus je commence avec
vovous Luc. Votre réaction faceà
cece plan?
- - Le plan essaie de ménager
l'l'chef, c'est-à-dire qu'on va
cocontinuer à produire du gaz et
dudu pétrole au même rythme qu'n
enen produit en ce moment, et me
auaugmenté. Et on va reporter le
plplus tard possible la réductin
dedes GS qui sont liés au
trtransport. Or, il y a trois
popossibilités de réduire notre
emempreinte carbone : le pétrol,
lele
lele transport.
- - Êtes-vous d'accord avec cete
ididée qu'on va varier justemen,
ququ'on va y aller par secteur.
PaParce que ce qu'on demande au
sesecteur pétrolier, c'est moins
lolourd, moins imposant que
d'd'autreses secteurs. On a un
tatableau à vous montrer justemt
ququi montre cette logique.
AvAvec le principe de base, este
quque vous êtes d'accord avec
cecela, Luc?
- - Oui, tout à fait. Dans les
dédéchets, une bonne partie des
memesures qui devaient être miss
enen place ont été mises en pla,
avavec les services de composta.
IlIl restait chose à faire, mais
onon voit qu'il n'y a pu
auaugmentation enfin.
L'L'agriculture, il n'y a pas de
gagains à faire. De toute manièe
ilil y a une augmentation prévu.
UnUne augmentation de la
popopulation, de la production
agagricole, c'est normal qu'il y
a a pas de réduction. Les
bbâtiments, ça va prendre du
tetemps, parce qu'on ne
rereconstruit pas nos maisons
totoutes les cinq ans. Par comp,
onon le fait avec nos véhicules.
AlAlors c'est normal que c'est à
vivitesse variable.
- - Et votre réaction, Michel?
- - Beaucoup de scepticisme,
d'd'abord parce qu'on n'a
jajamais... nos cibles à effet e
seserre.
AlAlors comment on peut penser e
avavec des cibles pas trop
cocontraignantes et... il ne fat
papas oublier, 2030, c'est dans
papas très longtemps, c'est
prpresque demain. C'est une groe
bobouchée à avaler.
JeJe me sens pas très
etet dire qu'ils ont trouvé la
foformule pour réussir cette fo-
cici alors que toutes les autres
fofois ça n'a pas marchée.
- - Avez-vous autant de
scscepticisme, Hélène Pigot
- - Pas autant. Ça s'explique
paparce qu'on veut être le plus
efefficace possible. On va faire
leles mesures qui sont les plus
sususceptibles de nous r rapporr
bebeaucoup en termes de réductin
dede GS. Je pense par exemple au
sesecteur de l'électricité, où n
didit que les réductions sont ds
8888 %. Le chiffre paraît gros,
mamais c'est parce qu'il y a
enencore beaucoup de production
d'd'électricité au Canada qui se
fafait par la combustion du
chcharbon, qui est une substance
exextrêmement polluante
évévidemment. Et c'est très
fafacile, entre guillemets, de
fafaire une transition, ne sera-
cece que vers le gaz naturel.
CeCertains diront que ce n'est s
unun gros gain, mais on gagne
ququand même 30 % d'efficacité r
rarapport au charbon. C'est une
trtradition très facile à faire.
BrBref, dans ce secteur, on peut
fafacilement transformer notre
élélectricité est allé chercher
dedes gros gain. Sur la question
dedes transports, comme Luc le
didit, diminution de 10 % c'est
trtrès peu.
OnOn laisse un peu de l'os,
papassez-moi l'expression, aux
auautomobilistes qui veulent
cocontinuer d'utiliser leur
vovoiture. Clairement, on pense
ququ'à partir de 2030 recommencs
àà augmenter la vente...
- - avec des obligations, parce
quque c'est par étapes?
- - Exactement. On pense qu'il y
auaura une courbe exponentielleà
papartir de 2030, et que c'est e
sesecteur des transports, dans a
dedeuxième tranche nos
obobligations, qui fera la plus
grgrosse part des diminutions.
- - Maintenant, la réaction de .
SiSingh. Une entente qui nous an
pepeu surpris entre le NPD et le
PaParti libéral pour finalement
avavoir un gouvernement stable.n
nene basculera pas en élection
avavant la fin du mandat de
MoMonsieur Trudeau. Mais encore
fafaut-il que le NPD soit
sasatisfait de ce qu'on lui off.
OnOn va l'écouter.
JAJAGMEET SINGH, chef, NPD
- - La ligne est écrite dans
l'l'entente. Le fait qu'on a une
cicible comme j'ai donné
d'd'éliminer les subventions
pépétrolières, c'est quelque che
ququi n'est pas dans l'annonce
dudu gouvernement.
O On a le droit, on a la
popossibilité de retirer notre
apappui. Mais j'ai confiance qun
pepeut utiliser cette entente pr
fafaire mieux pour les gens, por
foforcer le gouvernement de livr
lala marchandise.
- - Est-ce qu'il est en train de
didire qu'il faut en faire plus
hahaut qu'il a mis de l'eau dans
soson vin?
- - Il est en train de dire les
dedeux.
MaMais M. Singh va être... il vt
êêtre parti de l'opposition et n
mmême temps avoir signé une
enentente qui dit sur une questn
dede confiance va voter pour le
gogouvernement. C'est le genre e
sisituation un peu inconfortabl:
jeje n'aime pas ça, mais c'est s
sisi mal, qu'on va entendre
sosouvent de la part du NPD.
- - Parlons du budget. On a appt
lala date aujourd'hui, le 7 avr.
VoVous vous attendiez à quoi,
HéHélène?
- - Bien, écoutez, je ne suis ps
dadans le secret des dieux, mais
cece qu'on va regarder évidemme,
dedeux choses : les dépenses
mimilitaires, est-ce qu'elles
auaugmenteront dans le contextee
lala guerre en Ukraine? On
reregardera ça avec attention.
MaMais aussi, le budget répondr-
t-t-il aux attentes du NPD faceà
cecette nouvelle entente qui a é
sisignée la semaine passée? En
paparticulier, la question des
sosoins dentaires. Entente qui t
quque cette année, les soins
dedentaires pour les moins de 12
anans devraient être couverts.
DoDonc c'est très court comme
écéchéancier. Et cela, évidemme,
c'c'est susceptible d'ouvrir un
frfront avec les provinces. Je
pepense notamment au Québec, où
leles soins dentaires pour les
jejeunes de 10 ans et moins sont
cocouverts, ou presque tous
cocouverts.
BrBref, on va regarder si ça
dededans, mais aussi la réaction
dedes provinces à cela, parce qe
jeje ne suis pas certain que
totoutes les provinces sont
enenchantées à l'idée d'élargir
enencore le panier de services
sasanté couverts.
- - Luc, vos attentes?
- - Dans l'entente entre Singh t
TrTrudeau, il était clair que
c'c'était les questions de santé
etet les questions sociales qui
prprenaient le haut du pavé.
L'L'environnement, ça a été
ajajouté, mais c'était pas
l'l'essentiel de l'entente. Alos
ilil va faire très attention à e
quque les soins dansants sont ds
lele prochain budget.
LaLa deuxième chose, on a une
ininflation galopante. La
trtroisième chose, on a une vic-
prpremière ministre qui est... i
veveut dépenser dans l'armée, ac
unun projet de 9 milliards. Il a
dede gros projets : l'achat des
avavions F-35, et par la suite,
l'l'achat des bateaux soit poura
gagarde nationale soit pour le
miministère de la Défense. Ça me
fafait penser qu'il va y avoir n
énénorme budget inflationniste.
- - En moins d'une minute, Mich?
- - Pour l les Canadiens ordina,
l'l'inflation ce n'est pas des..
c'c'est des dépenses quotidienn.
IlIl va falloir aussi qu'il fase
trtrès attention à cela, parce
ququ'il y a plusieurs provinces
ququi s'en vont en élection
bibientôt. Ça pourrait créer des
frfrictions avec les provinces i
cece budget est trop
exexpansionniste et trop
ininflationniste.
- - Et le test que ça représente
popour cette entente avec le NP?
- - Le test et permanent, mais e
NPNPD à la fin peut bien dire ce
ququ'il veut, ils ne peuvent paà
cece moment-ci se retirer de cee
enentente.
IlIls vont être obligés de trour
leles bons côtés mêmes dans ce
ququ'ils aiment moins.
- - Alors, on verra!